في غير اتجاه التصعيد تتحرك سياسيا مواقف
فرقاء الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا دون
انجازات ميدانيه ملموسه تتوالى يوميات
القصف المتبادل في نقاط التماس فيما يشبه
مراوحه للمكان منذ الاستيعاده الاوكرانيه
لخرسون الوضع الميداني القائم رغم احتدام
المعارك رافقته تصريحات سياسيه متفاوته
بشان التسويه يقول الروس انه مستعدون لها
في حال وجود مقترح جدي ويستدعي وزير
الخارجيه سرجراف خطاب ما قبل الحرب بشان
مخاوف بلاده من توسع النيش
وخصوصا الولايات المتحده كدوله تقود الحلف
يرفضون دون خجل كما تذكرون الاعتراف بانها
وعدت كل من كربه
بعدم التوسع الشرقان رغم وجود ادله كثيره
تؤكد انهم يكذبون
على الطرف المقابل جاء نفي امين عام حلف
شمال الاطلسي يونس ستارتر برج بوجود فرص
للسلام في اوكرانيا حاليا
المسؤولون في واشنطن يوصلون من جهتهم
تاكيد دعم اوكرانيا في الحرب ولكن مع
اشارات واضحه على الصبغه الدفاعيه لهذا
الدعم
الاوكرانيين من تنفيذ ضربات داخل روسيا
لكن المهم هو ان نفهم ما يعانيه
الاوكرانيون يوميا جراء العدوان الروسي
المستمر
الامريكي النسبي للدعم الذي يفهم من كلام
ليكن وزنه لايت اوستن وزير الدفاع في نفس
المؤتمر الصحفي حين نفى منع بلاده
لاوكرانيا من تطوير قدرتها الذاتيه علشان
ضربات بعيده المدى اي في العمق الروسي كان
ما لسانه واشنطن لحليفتها كيف لن نفعلها
نحن ولكن يفعلوها ان شئتم وهي تبدو رساله
للجانب الروسي اكثر من كونها مجرد ابراء
ذمه امام الحليف الاوكراني لم تحجب تلك
المواقف السياسيه غبار المعارك التي ما
زالت دائره على الارض يقول الجيش
الاوكراني الى القوات الروسيه تواصل قصفها
على مقاطعات الجنوب والشرق حيث تركز
هجومها على باخ موت التي نفذت فيها خلال
الساعات الماضيه عشرات الضربات الجويه
والهجمات الصاروخيه على مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه مقابل تنفيذ الجانب الاوكراني
غارات على مواقع تمركز روسيا واسقاط مسيره
روسيه في عدد من خطوط التماس من جانبها
تحدثت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن اسقاط
طائرات الاوكرانيه مسيره في لوجان واسقاط
طائره اوكرانيه من طراز سوخي 24 فوق ارتي
موكا بمقاطعه دونتستك وتدمير عشرات
الصواريخ من طراز هاي مارس في كريفا روج
وسط اوكرانيا